Japón negocia con la otan la apertura de
una oficina será la primera de la
organización militar occidental en Asia
la noticia fue desvelada días atrás por
el medio Nike y ha sido confirmada por
el ministro de exteriores japonés
yoshimasasi en la CNN esa oficina que
abriría el año que viene profundizará la
huella de la organización al dentista en
el Pacífico después de que el año pasado
fueran invitados por primera vez a la
cumbre en Madrid países como Japón Corea
del Sur o Australia ayaxy ha explicado
que la invasión de Ucrania ha convertido
al mundo en un lugar más inseguro ya
mencionado en varias ocasiones a Rusia
sin embargo cuesta no ver a Rusia como
un problema pasajero y a China como la
razón principal de esa oficina con china
se juega a Estados Unidos a primacía
global y con china acumula Japón pleitos
históricos y discusiones territoriales
Estados Unidos ya tienen Asia a cuarta
lavas a decenas de miles de tropas y
apadrina a organiza militares como el
aucus y el quad en la otan sería pues la
última vuelta de tuerca en su estrategia
china ya protestó la semana pasada
Cuando surgió la noticia dijo que Asia
es un lugar para la cooperación y el
desarrollo Pacífico y que no Debería ser
la plataforma para los países que buscan
pelea geopolítica chinguán el ministro
de exteriores chino ha dicho en Alemania
que la principal amenaza para la
seguridad en Europa es cierto país no ha
mencionado el nombre que exporta su
mentalidad de guerra fría a todo el
mundo